Meet Esmeralda Flores.
She is a home cleaner in New York City.
And like so many home cleaners,
she's using a tech platform, an app,
to connect to clients.
But unlike other home cleaners,
she's making $25 an hour,
which is twice as much as she used to make
at her previous company.
And she makes a living wage.
There's no algorithmic boss at her company
that changes the pay or hours
from under her feet,
so she has some stability for her family.
And every week, the workers
at this company are meeting
to decide how to run this company.
They decide on the operations.
Esmeralda receives training
in finance and management,
and in conflict resolution.
And it really makes her grow
as a person within that company.
So now, you might be asking, like,
"What kind of company is that?
I've never heard of a tech platform
that gives benefits like that.
How do they do that?"
So the answer is Up and Go,
and it's not your typical tech platform.
It’s what is called
a “platform cooperative,”
which means that the workers,
the house cleaners,
are sharing the governance
and the ownership of this platform.
They are deciding on wages,
they are deciding on benefits,
they are deciding
what customers are charged.
And it's a truly democratic workplace,
and I think that's really
what we need more of right now.
If you think of tech platforms
denying workers living wages,
if you think about them
denying them the right to organize,
and expanding economic
inequality in the process,
I think platform co-ops
are one way to change that.
I know, I know, that for some of you,
when you hear the word "co-op,"
you immediately think
of a white guy like me
standing in a food
cooperative in Berkeley,
selling you vegan cheese, right?
(Laughter)
And I love food cooperatives,
but they are not the only
type of cooperative.
Co-ops are really just a group of people
who have a shared need,
be that vegan cheese or housecleaning,
and they come together
to address that need.
And that might be a business,
and sometimes, it takes on other forms,
but it's always about shared ownership
and democratic governance.
So co-ops are nothing new.
You've heard about them.
The consumer co-ops as we know them today
exist since 1844, when textile weavers
in the north of England
came together because
their pay was cut in half
and their families were starving,
so they decided to sell oatmeal
and sugar and flour through a store,
a cooperative.
Today, cooperatives of agriculture,
not just food co-ops, are quite big,
so you may have heard
of Land O'Lakes or Ocean Spray.
And so, platform cooperatives take
the best from these tried-and-true models,
the 200-year-old model of the cooperative
and the much younger model
of the digital platform,
and bring them together.
So here's what makes them different.
They are made up of a group of people
who get an equal vote in decision-making,
and they are genuinely
sharing that process,
so when it comes to how much
customers should be charged,
how much workers should be paid,
and also, whether or not
data should be collected
and to whom they are sold.
And there is another thing
that makes them different,
which is that they are scaling equality.
And so, take Esmeralda Flores.
That's where she works
in the cleaning industry,
which has an annual turnover
of 75 percent.
So Esmeralda has been with Up and Go
almost since its beginning,
so for three years.
And one of the reasons
that she stuck with the company
is that she was paid more.
So that is significant in the context of,
typical tech platforms would take
between 25 and 50 percent commission,
which is an exorbitant amount
for immigrants,
who make up the majority
of the gig economy workforce.
So the women at Up and Go
decided to take five percent commission,
which they use to run the platform
and pay for credit card bills.
And 95 percent go to the women,
go to the workers themselves.
And one reason
that the company can do that,
that Esmeralda can be paid so much,
is that there's no fiduciary duty
to the shareholders to maximize profit.
And here's another thing that makes
platform cooperatives different:
it is that everybody at this company
owns it together,
so it's a shared ownership,
which means that also
the intellectual property of the software
is owned together.
That means that they can create
a small network of companies,
like a social franchise,
and scale up this company,
to then compete
against large tech companies.
And lastly, consider that Up and Go
is made up mostly of immigrants
from Latin America,
and if they were a typical
gig-economy platform
and they were out to look
for venture-capital funding,
then the research shows us very clearly
that the chances of these
minority-women-led founder teams
to find venture-capital funding
are very slim, in the single percentile,
meaning that these women
would have never been even able
to build a platform in the first place,
or add some much needed diversity
to the tech founders' club.
So, today, there are hundreds
of platform co-ops like Up and Go,
all over the world,
and they work.
And they work in more ways than one.
They work because they are
more resilient in times of crisis,
they are more productive,
they retain workers longer,
and often, they pay better.
So I really believe that platform co-ops
are a better, fairer alternative,
and that's why a few years ago,
together with a few friends,
I started the Platform
Cooperativism Consortium --
try to say that three times, fast --
at The New School in New York City.
And essentially, what we do is we support
platform cooperatives,
digital cooperative projects,
all over the world.
We are working with 500 projects
and businesses in over 30 countries.
But let me just give you
a bit of a taste of this.
I have two examples
that are really close to my heart.
One is Co-op Ride,
which is a driver-owned taxi platform
with some 3,500 drivers
that make between 10 and 30 percent more
than the drivers on these large
ride-hailing platforms.
The passengers pay five percent less.
And already, despite this being
a very new company,
it's already one of the largest
worker cooperatives in the United States.
Second, Fairbnb,
which is a community-focused alternative
to short-term rental platforms
and will soon be available
in 120 cities and villages
with over 4,500 hosts.
Half of Fairbnb's commission
goes to community projects.
One of those is a food-distribution
center in Genoa, Italy.
Now, I know, I know,
you might be wondering,
when you hear about Up and Go,
Fairbnb and Co-op Ride,
you might be wondering,
"How is this not a total mess?"
So the entrepreneurs among you
must be thinking,
"God, democratic workplace?"
And the answer is, "Well, they do
what everybody else is doing,"
which is they are hiring management.
And they are hiring tech workers.
But there's one big difference, right?
And that is that the rules of operation
are decided by all.
So the management executes the rules
that were actually decided
by all the people in this company.
I've told you about platform co-ops
mostly in the labor sector,
and also transportation,
mobility and short-term rental,
but they can also transform
entire sectors,
such as the care sector,
culture and the arts, higher education
and the data economy.
I mean, just imagine, if our data
would be managed cooperatively,
cooperative data trusts,
data cooperatives.
Or imagine a social-media cooperative,
where the users own the platform
and decide what is done with the data,
which data are collected
and to whom they are sold,
So one where there is
no fiduciary duty to shareholders,
to maximize profits,
so that you can actually build in
privacy and transparency
and really bring the benefits back
to those who actually generated the data.
So I know we are here,
near Silicon Valley,
so I can see that, I'm sure,
for many of you,
you will think, "Wow,
I'm not so sure about this.
I mean, this would just
never scale, right?"
I've heard this many times.
And it doesn't, right?
It doesn't scale like traditional
Silicon Valley companies.
Well, it kind of does.
Up and Go's sales increased by 97 percent,
from 2018 to 2019,
but that's really not the objective.
The platform cooperatives
are not about going public,
they are not about maximizing profits.
They scale differently,
they scale more affordably
than brick-and-mortar cooperatives.
They scale by creating
networks of companies
that then compete against large companies.
They scale more quickly,
because their co-op
can be anywhere in the world,
and they scale democracy,
because they can be decentralized
through crypto networks and blockchain.
And that is why I want instructors
to teach about this model
in law schools and business schools.
That's why I want
entrepreneurs to start one
instead of another
traditional tech platform.
And that’s why I want incubators
to include this model
and also unions
to start platform cooperatives.
And that’s why I want
ethical social impact investors
to consider them and create
an amazing legacy of equality.
Now, I'm not here to tell you
that this one model will eradicate
economic inequality forever.
It's not, right?
But what we need
is more variety in the economy.
We need small, unionized
private businesses,
we need employee ownership,
and we need platform cooperatives.
We face big challenges.
But here's what gives me a lot of hope.
When markets fail
and the safety nets
of governments break down,
people turn to each other, right?
People start to cooperate
by forming food cooperatives
so that they can feed themselves
during a crisis.
They start to form platform cooperatives
so that they can clean homes
and still make a living wage.
And when markets and governments
for too long failed to address
structural racism and inequality,
people form institutions,
like the Black Panthers'
Free Breakfast Program for Children
and the AFL-CIO, the largest federation
of unions in the United States.
So we saw democracy,
or the aspiration
to participatory democracy,
spread across countries around the world,
and now, it's time for it
to spread in the workplace.
Thank you.
(Applause)